thanks emily for the presentation for
the introduction this is absolutely
terrifying standing in front of people
after
three years of being alone at home
so please indulge
before i get to possible futures for
jupiter i just wanted to say a little
bit more about myself so
i'm the founder of quant stack quant
stack is a team of open source
developers
working on some of the major project you
know projects and software of the
open source stack that we all know and
love such as jupiter canada forge and a
lot more
we're primarily based in france germany
austria and in the uk
so you can check out quant stack
as an open source developer i'm mostly
involved in the jupiter
project and can't afford
and i'm also doing a lot of
i would say volunteer work as a director
of num focus and the organizer of the
pilot affairs meetup
so before i get to the possible features
i just want to give you a quick update
on
what's going on in the jupiter project
but wait
do you all understand my
americanized french this is going on all
right
um so the one of the most exciting
things that happened uh in the past year
in the jupiter project
is
the introduction of the jupiter visual
debugger so you can now actually debug
notebooks and files interactively in
jupyter lab as of triple tab 3.0
this is still ongoing a lot of there is
still a lot of
improvements to that ongoing and jupiter
lab 4 will be even better
but well it's based on the dap from
microsoft it's language agnostic
and
we already have three kernels supporting
debugging
the next
exciting development of the past year in
jupiter lab was
the collaborative editing in jupiter lab
in the sense of you know collaborative
editing just like in google docs
it's been a long-standing request of the
community for many years and our
implementation is based on similarities
which are conflict-free replicated data
types so you have automatic
resolving of conflicts
so we support undo redo by users etc and
for gypted up lab4
major refactor is ongoing
uh
introducing role-based access control
improving stability of collaborative
editing
and providing persistent collaborative
editing sessions so that you can undo
your changes
since the very beginning of your
document
um jupiter lab 4 will also be a lot
faster so frederic connell val who works
with me at constant has
started
his effort to improve the jupiter
performances
with um the development of a
benchmarking tools and
after we were able to measure
performance
in a more scientific way we
did some major improvements to the
rendering of jupyter notebooks to the
table of content and the search tools
and there are even greater improvements
coming up for 4.0 with a virtual
rendering of notebooks so that we only
really render the parts of the notebook
that are currently in the screen
so
yeah and so the benchmarks that you can
see on the right are actually produced
by this new benchmarking tool and they
show the improvements coming from the
update to codemirror6 which is the
the
text editor that we use for jupiter lab
now another really important development
going on right now in the by and done by
other members of the community
is the work and accessibility so one in
five people
which is
really a large proportion has a physical
visual auditory cognitive or
neurological disability that
makes using web applications
difficult
and
this gets even more difficult with
complex applications like jupiter so the
chansey kerberg initiative is funding a
team at quan side to improve this
situation in the jupiter project so
there is a most of the focus goes to
jupiter lab and they are working right
now on automated testing documentation
and outreach
um
another thing still in jupiter lab the
language server protocol which is what
powers you know the refactoring
abilities of vs code and you know the
warnings and autocomplete
based on static analysis of the code is
becoming core to jupiter lab so this has
been developed for several years by
michelle and nick as an extension and
now this is being integrated into coral
jupiter lab
so that's for jupiter lab now
has anyone in the room heard of jupiter
light before
so that's not many but
i think this is one of the most
transformative projects
that
will you know really change the way you
do interactive computing
in on the web so jupyter lite is an
in-browser distribution of jupiter lab
what it means is that the kernels
which normally run on the server side
now run in the web browser
so it's a simple thing to do when it
comes to js based kernels such as a
javascript kernel
but for the python we actually use
a
wasm-based distribution of c python
provided by the periodic project
benefits of this are a high scalability
because you don't need to provide an
elastic
cloud infrastructure to serve many many
users on the web you can simply serve
all of this you know your kernel and all
of the packages that are required to run
your computation are static assets
alongside your html and javascript
and it now powers the interactive shells
on the numpy.org and simpli.org websites
so you can try that there is a
live console that serves the million of
millions of monthly visitors of
numpy.org
right in the front page
and when you load it
there is you don't have a dedicated
server there is no docker image running
for you in the background you just run c
python in the browser and that comes
with numpy simpy scipy batteries
included you can do plotting and
everything
and
it's really hard to
understand the importance of that
on top of jupiter light we're now
working on a successor to pio died based
on the mamba package manager so for
those who don't know mamba momba is a c
plus plus reimplementation of canda
that produces a much faster experience
for canada and can also be built in
webassembly
so
the goal of this
new distribution called m script and
forge is to enable long-term long-term
reproducibility or binder-like
environment so that you can distribute
all of the packages that you need for a
given computation
as a bundle
alongside your notebook on a web page
without having to do any server
infrastructure
other ongoing developments
we have been telling the community that
jupiter lab was going to replace the
classic notebook for many years
but many users were very attached to the
classic notebook user interface
and were
complaining that we were not maintaining
that package so much anymore
and so instead of sunsetting the
notebook
we made the decision to sunrise the
classic notebook
and
to create
a
classic notebook experience
that would be based on the same
technical foundations as jupiter lab but
you know
uh with all of the you know new
developments that came into drip lab
such as collaborative editing debugging
and whatnot so in the jupiter
enhancement proposal the jupiter
leadership
voted that notebook 7.0
will retain the document-centric
interface and provide a very similar ui
to the notebook v6
and we will port the main missing
extensions to the jupiter lab extension
system such as rise and then be greater
if you are using jupiter for teaching
and there are already pre-releases
available for
notebook 7 and this is actually what you
get when you hit try the jupyter
notebook on the jupyter website already
so
this was just a sneak peek on what's
going on right now in the jupiter
ecosystem there is a lot more that i
haven't talked about like jupiter booked
food beautiful publication quality books
and documents from computational
documents
content jupiter hub obviously voila
which turns notebooks into standalone
applications and dashboards
binder jupyter games if you haven't
looked
at jupyter games yet check it out it's
really awesome
now on the community side
we by we i mean here the jupiter
community and the jupiter uh community
building committee hired a new event
organizer for
uh building up uh the two main programs
that we we've had so far
the uh jupiter khan conference which
already happened three times
and uh the jupiter community workshops
so um girl yeah this is gail kellington
and she joined the team
a few months ago so please give her a
round of applause
i can't stay
i can't say too much but we're working
on bringing back to pitch in 2023
another really important thing that's
going on at the social side of the
jupiter project is that there is a major
refactor
of the jupiter governance ongoing so the
main goals of that refactor was to
ensure that the project governance
reflects our values
and supports the growth of the project
and we also warned that jupiter remains
a multi-stakeholder project and is not
controlled by a single group
organization so for two years the new
governance has been developed by
community members and voted upon by the
current project leadership in a series
of weekly course
so it's basically a constitution
important parts of the new governance
are already in effect there we now have
a body of jupiter distinguished
contributors which is
an award that we
give every year to major contributors to
the project we now have sub-project
consoles for the main sub-projects of
the of jupiter project
and we have the jupiter software
steering console that that is uh now
being set
up um
yeah as i was showing all of these
slides i showed like the pictures of the
main people involved in these aspects
and
that's all of them and this is only a
small portion of the jupiter development
community
so let's talk about the future
so here are the rules of the game
i'll be making some bold claims about
possible futures for jupiter but it's
not an official roadmap don't quote me
on that as this is what the project the
project is going to do right this
some of them are just around the corners
but others are mere possibilities right
and
and my claims are going to get bolder
and bolder
it's just an opinionated take
so in the future
jupiter light
will enable the next 10 million jupiter
users
and more
why the scalability anyone who can host
static assets on the web
can embed
a console on their website
without coding to a third-party service
or anything if you can
host an apache server somewhere
that will work
and it already powers the interactive
shells of websites that have millions of
visitors mostly right such as jupiter
and number
so it really allows the bar to deploy a
jupiter-based teaching platform you
don't you don't need a scalable cloud
infrastructure
so
countries and teaching institutions
that don't have that kind of
infrastructure already available for
them
won't need
to rely on other countries to deploy a
sovereign
service for
for their schools and universities and i
can't really overstate how important
that is
so what i think will happen is that high
schoolers around the world will learn
the basics of python and other common
scripting language in the web browser
in the future
jupiter light
and absorptive forge which is this new
wasm distribution that we're building
will enable long-term software
reproducibility
so
scrimptonforge brings the power of the
moba and cada package managers to the
web browser
so that the entire execution environment
can be built and bundled in this in the
form of static assets for a website
so this static bundle is a time capsule
for producing your computation in the
long run
wasm is a web standard
so it's very likely that binaries that
you build now in wasm will have
will be executable for a much longer
period of time that's something that you
build for today's version of linux on an
x86 platform right it's very likely to
still run in a few decades from now
so
in the future
entire curricula will be built upon
computational documents
so this actually is a quote of lorena
barbara's presentation
at cypa i think a few years back
jupiter will be key in implement in
implementing computational thinking so
learning how to build jupiter
applications will support solving
problems
in all disciplines
so
the problem we have at the moment is
that
computing and programming is start as a
separate subject and not really used
for teaching
history biology and whatnot at you know
in high schools and lower levels
and
what we think
is that we should put this into action
into use as early as possible in the
curriculum of these subjects
[Music]
in the future
jupiter will be accessible to everyone
why
because we really don't have a choice
one in five people
need
has a disability that can make using web
applications difficult so we cannot
address an entire generation of new
developers and student without fixing
that
so what's jupiter doing about it so
there is a cci funded grant a cdf added
team at quan site
at constant we're also working on a
grant for jupiter in education that has
a strong focus on accessibility there
there is some ongoing development
we are migrating jupiter laptop 6. that
this brings some performance
improvements
but it also makes
easy critical steps towards towards
making jupiter accessible
in the future jupiter lab will serve as
the foundation for specialized technical
computing not just development or data
science
just think about it
if you're looking for
good framework to build a complex
application i don't know maybe an email
client
a photo editing software a cad modeler
an ide
from scratch
you need a plugin system
you need common plugins for themes
command palette file browsing
a settings editor
you need integrated tools for regression
for visual regression testing and
benchmarks
you need the foundations to make your
application collaborative
you shouldn't start from scratch you
should use an existing generic set of
foundations to build such an application
and this is already the case like
gyptella brass elira quetz jupite are
remixes of jupiter lab extensions
and many more
so my claim is that
the future of
cad
or photo editing
may actually rely on the same
foundations that we built
to make jupiter lab
and actually in the future your go-to
ide for c plus plus development may
actually be built on jupiter lab
we're already working on that
providing visual debugging experience to
jupyter lab
supporting you know the lsp protocol
so
if you are building an ide or if you're
building ide extensions you shouldn't
build on borrowed land right
so
vs code is
only partly open source right it's great
but we you don't get to choose a
direction and the the ground may shift
under your feet right
so if you really want to
be part of a community where you can
have a weight
i think that jupiter lab is a much
better bet
in the future
all web-based authoring software will be
collaborative and by collaborative i
mean collaborative in the collaborative
editing sense
and
what we've known we all know since the
pandemics that you know using shared
document to build
you know
a road map or something that you have to
work on with peers
is completely ubiquitous for text-based
documents right
and the way we have solved this in
jupiter lab using yjs
is actually not specific to textual
content it will work for other kinds of
structured data such as cad photo
editing
and my claim is that in the future if
you want to build a web-based experience
for photo editing or cad you will want
to make it collaborative you will want
to have
people in the same company who work on
the same 3d model i don't know for jet
engine to be able to look at it together
in a in a real time
in a real-time fashion you want the
person that's the closest to the
silicone making simulations in the jet
engine
to be able to annotate
the same document as someone who is
working in the shed and look in is
closer to the metal
so
these were bold claims
um
i think that they're not so crazy but
well they're not all true right now so i
hope that
you
will help contribute to them and make
them a reality thank you
[Applause]